Sperman's theory of intelligence address the question how intelligent are you?
And the evidence for this theory is fairly strong. Sperman found that the
correlations across the three domains were about positive .6 and .7. Now this
is on a correlation scale between negative 1 and positive 1. And because it's
positive, the 2 scores will go in the same direction. So as one score
increases, so does the other score. Still to this day modern tests of
intelligence show that the 3 primary domains of intelligence are positively
correlated. Supporting the view that intelligence is one general ability. Now
it's important to remember That theories drive scientific research. A theory
doesn't necessarily mean it's a law, regardless of how strong the correlations
are. Theories can change and be adapted over time. The theory that intelligence
is one, basic set of related skills is known as the g-factor theory of
intelligence. This is the foundation for the idea that intelligence Can be
represented by a single number. This theory organizes intelligence into a
hierarchy. With general intelligence. Or g at the top. And from there extends
three specific domains. Your spatial abilities. Your mathematical abilities.
And your verbal abilities. Until recently, all of the major tests of
intelligent, has been based on Sprimen's theory.